before we witness hip hop greatness take
the stage we're gonna deep dive into the
e.t vault to when we first met them
[Music]
e.t first met the queen of hip-hop soul
in 1995 on the heels of her second
number one album my life
i mean this is the second double
platinum album so i have to be doing
something right
in 2001 e.t was on the field when the
then 29 year old had her first hail mary
moment on the super bowl stage she
performed alongside aerosmith britney
spears and nsync it was amazing i just
remember having this red spiky hair and
this
bright lime green fur on and i was a
rock star that year it was hot and
speaking of hot looks pop it like it's
hot pop it like it's hot i always gotta
bring the look his hairdo his outfit in
1996 he was still having a fashion
moment with e.t what's my name
so what do you call this look snoop it's
the dog father look it's my new look
baby cause you represent
and while snoop has collaborated with
everyone from katy perry to mariah carey
our favorite duo is snoop and martha
stewart uh he taught me quite a few
things a new vocabulary a chisel yes a
vernaculars yeah martha told us she will
be there on sunday martha is such a big
fan of eminem i'm gonna finally let you
guys meet hi my name is now i have my
tickets everything's all set
[Music]
both snoop and eminem were put on the
map thanks to fellow halftime performer
dr dre he signed eminem nine years after
this freshman year high school photo dr
dre don't just stand there operate i got
dr dre out here and i got a lot of
supporters rallying around behind me
eminem's meteoric rise culminated in
2002 when his number one hit lose
yourself from the number one film eight
mile won the oscar for best original
song
the oscar goes to eminem
the then 30 year old skipped the show
but returned in 2020 for a surprise
performance
[Music]
afterwards eminem tweeted quote sorry it
took me 18 years to get here i don't
even want you congratulations dr dre has
also played a crucial role in the career
of fellow compton native and halftime
performer kendrick lamar fun fact they
both went to the same high school i see
my seat kind of like in the same area
stevie wonder i want to meet him
that was the star struck rapper in 2013
before his 13 grammy wins including one
with taylor swift for bad blood and you
got to live with the bad blood now did
you ever see this possibly happening for
yourself oh man um i'd be lying if i
said i did
now when it comes to dr dre e.t first
met him in 1993 on the heels of his
first solo album the chronic e.t oh yeah
nothing but a g thing baby
[Music]
dre of course came to fame in the 80s
with the groundbreaking rap group nwa
tell them where you're from straight out
of compton
in 2015 dre co-produced their critically
acclaimed biopic straight out of compton
what was it like when you first saw it
it was goosebumps a little bit surreal
but you won't get a crumb for me cause
i'm from the streets of
you